à l'écran Yannick Noa un artiste ancien
sportif qu'on ne présente plus la
personnalité préférée des Français a
accepté la proposition de la présidente
du conseil général pariner un jeune et
l'accompagner un bout de chemin dans son
parcours de vie en en souhaitant à cette
opération vraiment un un plein succès en
souhaitant à cette belle rencontre
humaine pareil des un avenir et et et
des jours qui vont inscrire la réunion
dans ce qu'elle est déjà et qu'on ne
doit pas perdre qu'on ne doit pas
oublier
nous sommes vraiment un territoire de
solidarité pariner ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire tout simplement être là
présent pas un papa pas une maman mais
vraiment une écoute une présence pour se
dire que on peut être une main tendue
pendant 18 mois pour suivre un jeune
mettre de la cohérence entre les
dispositifs administratifs qui existe et
puis l'implication humaine parce qu'au
fond les jeunes comme les moins jeunes
nous avons surtout besoin de l'affection
de l'amour du dialogue ce qui parfois
manque dans la vie de tous les jours où
tout le monde est pressé tout le monde a
ses problèmes et personne n'a plus
vraiment le temps aujourd'hui ce sont
plus de 320 parrains qui ont accepté eux
aussi de s'impliquer dans la vie d'un
jeune en perte de repère à l'image de
Dominique d'ambreville connu pour tenir
les reennes du centre lecture écriture
du brûlé découvrir l're c'est se
découvrir comprendre l'autre et se
comprendre moi je pense que
régulièrement on ira aussi sur le
terrain on ira voir vraiment je la
prendrai en main comme j'en ai fait pour
beaucoup j'ai fait pour beaucoup
et on va cheminer avec espoir surtout il
s'agit de dire aux jeunes il ne faut pas
se
désespérer on a la santé on a la
jeunesse et il faut y aller et tout
n'est pas perdu dans une île solidaire
c'est pour ça je m'inscrit dans ce
projet parce que c'est solidaire et ça
nous encourage à espérer demain mais
ensemble mine j'attends qu'elle
m'encourage vers l'emploi et qu'elle
mette m de de beaucoup de choses de
motivation mais beaucoup de jeunes a
besoin de motivation aujourd'hui voilà
bien tout le cœur de ce projet redonner
de l'humanité à la société redonner de
l'espoir c'est la volonté de naciim
Dindar et il semble que son message a
bien été compris je remercie vraiment la
présidente d'avoir eu cette ce projet
parce que souvent on dit que notre
jeunesse
c'est richesse mais notreesse
aujourd'hui est en desesérances jeis à
commencer par par je crois une phrase de
Martin Luther King qui a dit que pour
monter l'escalier il était tout d'abord
important de monter cette première
marche et c'est clairement je pense
notre rôle à tous de d'impulser la
montée de cette première marche et de
servir ensuite de rambarde de sécurité
pour aider ces jeunes motivés dans leur
démarche je pense que souvent on parle
de la jeunesse ronnaise et pour une fois
on a c'est une très belle initiative
dind vous avez su mettre l'humain au
cœur du dispositif en fait vous êtes
allé chercher à toucher les gens dans
leur cœur et pour ces jeunes qui sont
repris en main il s'agit vraiment de
repartir à zéro si leurs parins leur
donnent une seconde chance eux veulent
saisir cette opportunité pour sortir de
la galère je suis contente d'avoir ma
marine madame ba pour être aidé dans ma
vie par rapport à mes difficultés avoir
du soutien de l'écoute un coup de P dans
ma vie et je remercie Madame B d'être
pass je v travailler aujourd'hui j'ai un
enfant de 1 ans et et c'est pas possible
de vivre comme ça avec un enfant de 1 an
sonans travail quoi il faut que j'ai un
travail pour assurer mon enfant pour
aider mon enfant pour son avenir pour
aujourd'hui en fin de compte la
signature des premiers contrats
d'engagement s'est fait en présence des
élus du conseil général à terme ce sont
4000 jeunes qui devront être parinés
pour se faire un appel est lancé à tous
pour créer cette grande chaîne de
solidarité ce dispositif qui s'appuie
sur le pack jeune veut donner une
meilleure lisibilité en mobilisant les
services de la collectivité mais
également grâce à l'implication de
chacun des
pas